just in the morning it's just too early
for us too early but I'm going to
Seattle and so guess what we decided on
you and see other three oh yeah getting
on it getting on slight why guys with
low energy you know what guys low energy
unites white guys dressed like hipster
with fucking's walking dead white skin
here not not two white guys in sensible
shoes over caffeinated - yeah your
racist jokes are gonna go over great
what to deal with blacks everybody hey
alright hey Seattle [ __ ] blacks really
be allowed to vote woo thanks a lot good
night stay white everybody hey Seattle
I love how there's no pepper up in there
catch my drift hey guys how about this
racist thing doesn't bother me much you
know what I mean but then again I'm
white hey hey Seattle only racist when
it rains am i right how come I'm some
about the rain driving now having your
neck he didn't really have a job for
that what how come yeah how come Brandon
um anyway guys day when it rains that's
right yeah I stay out of Seattle not
start sucking a dick like we especially
go around them
hey man what get them off the stage oh
god right now and I'll say that it's
raining not say that's so weird bro it
is Ervin what time's your flight
okay I'm drinking mine if you sip into
the mic I'm all how long you man will
slap you for the fans now I'm thinkin
but did you know you can old and sip
coffee like that now listen hold on
there's nothing more there's nothing
worse when don't watch this when you
want to do exactly I'm sitting like this
they going to go like why hate with new
ideas they go they're talking eyes well
let me just authorize a talking and do
it Oh God just crank yeah they say that
the condition people you know like
people chewing loud or people sipping
stuff I go crazy it triggers me so I
guess it's a condition do you know what
it is - there's a term for it people
they can't list another be like smack
food
or slurp coffee literally I go crazy
trigger yeah it's a straight-up trigger
even my own daughter okay watch this to
my own daughter when she was like six
she would eat like it and I go we're
sitting there morning I go huh
I love my daughter but no no does it
again gotta help without though to my
god you got to keep it round close I am
so and I I would and I talk to there was
this like you have these parent meetings
yeah like about school and this one
woman goes you know I'm going to say
something and you know it's it's my
daughter twos and she makes this noise
and it drives me nuts and I actually
don't like her when she's chew health
food I start laughing so hard yeah for
me Jeremy it's a good like if I'm out
evening and some like that and if Joe's
chewing out or such my dad I'm like I I
literally I I'll have to leave or have
to say something Jake my brother came my
room he's eaten a wine gum and Dublin he
checked off and I went dude so he had a
problem as a kid I used to do it my dad
and if you want to get Jay to fight you
just go she just used to do my daddy's
to shush him like oh yeah he'd be
talking or eating a full Michael coach
man she goes really good yeah and so if
you got to Jay to trick any like freaks
out and stab people in the face
so um Jay used to do it and so Yoshi
Bailey said it just bothered I don't
know what's the condition calm whoo yeah
I have it to the 10th my father my
father when when you would be saying
stuff that he didn't agree with or that
was he considered you know stupid yeah
boy you would be making a point he'd
gone
okay let me let's try to let me try to
back you up a little bit cool because I
live in the real world and obviously
you're living in a fantasy world but I
will romance you for a second I will
roam it that kind of show you I'd be
like yeah there you go I like the way
you sped up when you didn't know you're
talking about you sped through that and
that I'd be like I'm gonna my I'm paying
out Jay had me dying and chin was there
Jay had me dying cuz he was like you
never went daddy's do this can my dad
come to town today and we story set to
do chores want us to choice yeah sure
tastes like [ __ ] goddamn slave labor was
like
Apple factor the shop out anyways he
would make us do all these chores and
barely pay us and he used to make us
wash the walls the light like you know
the walls all the time watch the laws
and jjcc with like stakeholders you take
like a kid off of Sandlot he was gonna
kill off Sam line and my big I don't
know your baby on that big a nerve so
that big as a kid my dad would walk by
and weekly expect and inspect the walls
and go but he go man I think we know try
to get your glasses fixed are they dirty
glasses doing oh my god I don't think so
yeah well it's weird because I seen you
know if you're trying to clean this wall
for an hour and it's turn Oh should we
take you to lunch after and see if we
can get you a bigger prescription
holding my god yeah oh my god eight was
telling my daddy still all the time I
was dying laughing I'm dying laughs well
that's my father I do that on my
standard pipe that where I do the same
work I didn't like milk and he'd go oh
yeah you don't like him he'll keep she
want bones look good in a dress because
I thought you want to play football yeah
baseball I'd be like uh but he he one
time ever say about Alaska when we went
fishing in Alaska and so my dad was a
marine you know all right but that was a
long time ago and we're in Alaska and my
father hires a guide and he he goes I
get a call and he goes we're gonna go
shoot bear in Alaska and I go no well
I'm not gonna shoot a bear either you
hold it at the Sun ah I don't know 33
okay your grooms your ham so I go but
you know father something new little
bonding go to Alaska the summertime
right see how you're yawning that's what
I started doing a TV when I heard ask
how many planes we got to take God take
two planes in a seaplane and then a boat
and then maybe die okay cool so he goes
we're gonna go bear hunting and I knew
he had been talking to somebody who got
in his ear about bear hunting I was like
oh man but he had already bought a rifle
and a scope now when my dad in
well my dad goes to buy rifle on the
scope it's the Joe Rogan school of Buyan
you go down to the highest price he
doesn't do any real secular level what's
the best one I got the best American
sniper open hey let me get the American
no get that very good all right so he
buys a cannon
it's we put it by the way we're going
fishing now
so we also bought ten thousand dollars
worth of fishing equipment I don't know
what it was but I remember I had to get
waders I don't know what you know
waiters are I don't don't care I was
it's like the waterproof pants sure are
yeah sure are completely yeah I very
quickly on that I lost every single door
every single door guy came over those
were yours ago I lost him because I was
fly-fishing he was what are you doing I
gotta get him caught in a tree in the
rakia and caught nothing I did it I feel
like fishes let me just try one so he's
gonna be you'll be no Gator surfing you
don't know you're fishing like jiu-jitsu
just don't try one correct yeah correct
and also you know oh by the way he's got
a huge sidearm in case
grizzly come after us will you catch him
the food yeah he got a side on so I'm
looking around for [ __ ] bear my
father goes I want to cite my rifle
want to cite it you know that means
because I don't like blend it up guess
so does yeah cuz you know you got a
messy enough Louise so uh we he I don't
think he knew what kind of rifle he'd
gotten but I remember looking at the
bullet and I was like that's a [ __ ]
yeah that bullets about seismic dong and
I got a piece on me alright this I'm
like I don't know how much gunpowder I
got in there we shooting planes down
right now okay we taking some planes
down so have you ever shot have you ever
shot a rifle with a scope okay so he
lies down and we put up a log like this
big that he don't have like the shirt on
no no no no we're in the wilderness we
go to the wilderness and he lies down he
decides to shoot it prone so I'm like up
next to him I'm looking at the [ __ ]
log he's gonna shoot I shoot alone he's
just you know huh and I let the lock
there and it was um it was made of like
it's been dried out yeah so uh he lies
down and this is day two okay I think we
got ten days last
Alaska rains all time in summertime so
he lies down and he he lines it up I'm
right next to mine do I want to see what
happens a log right next and he pulls
that trigger bro
now tell me but Youngblood it gave the
scope went into his eye so hard it was a
perfect ring looked like half a raccoon
we walked around Alaska and everybody
knew exactly what [ __ ] happen Telus
it was so loud though the gas escapes
the guns are so loud I literally could I
thought I was gonna have a home hearing
loss for the rest of my life uh guys
gonna shoot it with your mouth open
shoot away I was a white oh shoot yeah I
came out him and I was like all right I
tried that really [ __ ] hurt anyway
the ancestors [ __ ] yeah I don't they're
terrifying so Pat Kadampa oh yeah oh and
there was nothing left of log anyway I
was our that was our site is shut nice
to dogs last one day with fishing and
I'm trying to schedule vacation I was
looking last night I'm trying to go on
vacation I thought you'd done with the
Showtime stuff end of August mmm I
looked at Mexico people tell me go Tulum
I hear really good things yeah me too
it's rain season as I was looking like
why the ticket so cheap it's like a book
now oh my god damn it was it's a fourth
season oh my god dammit it's cheap out
there and I'm like right look at the
weather rainy every day yeah I was
raining every day and can't come can't
go it got very green for a reason
yeah yes it's the offseason mmm stuff
because when we tour like we do like
have been all over it's like a I don't
know where to go I don't really want to
go to an out-of-state that's Pam's
brother we live I don't want to go
anywhere no I don't want to go anywhere
I love it here but I gotta get out
otherwise they'll just work I know I
don't know where I'm gonna go Mexico's
out to looms out a hard bacon for shame
people were like I'll do it man it's
awesome whoops for sure tell me it's the
offseason yeah I would go I would go to
Europe but that's a better fly oh my god
no I'm just talking about a three-day
trip oh yeah the thing is not only two
days traveling back I'm saying I hear if
it that far that overhead a toss-up
major and I just and undoing yeah
there's also major jet lag
you know want to deal with that you want
to do 10 days until the jet jet like
from Dublin to here not bad at all
no Australian Giro right I went right
back my schedule yeah you guys are you
guys are still acclimated to LA yeah
I'll tell you what though
Australia here about two weeks is that
right a two-week supposedly yeah that's
no joke that was a beast Australia's
it's a different time zone can't have
that so NASA they said would you what
did you like more Australia or Dublin
and London and and listen I love
Australia Australia to me felt Sochi
where we're at in the major cities just
felt like a like a city in America I
heard that it's got bits amazing you
know one's great it but it's not exotic
it's not as like my love I felt like I
was somewhere else yeah yeah in
Manchester I kind of felt like those
somewhere else it was major city and
making sure major city in the shortened
Dublin is Dublin I agree and is Dublin
um very like it's like a maze isn't it
isn't it hard to find your way around
it's not real easy
oh really London for me was a B well of
course yeah the roads yes excuse me and
I'm looking one the little slide takes
the crab drivers three to three years
yeah I call the knuckle my cab driver I
went oh using Waze some of this tobacco
Diaz he look - in Lea's this is the main
road oh it in London it's this tiny
rodeos yeah man that's what sucks so bad
there's only people in the roads or
because they remain for a difficult
arrow like they just never advanced but
also they say that when taxi drivers
when they have to learn London it takes
in three years they call it the
knowledge London would be a differentl
yeah Dublin oh that was super easy
really hope we walked everywhere really
yeah Wow little streets same thing like
his no not really no London have those
tiny little streets right
that's why there's major cities I'm
coming I'm jealous I know at major city
London is those tiny little roads yeah
now there are stories about cars getting
stuck big cars trying to make it through
and can't yeah we'd have to pull over
wait for a car to come and go back in
yeah I literally I was like oh you're
using like a short tail like things like
not bits the regular road also driving
the other side of the road do they do
the same thing and oh yeah yeah yeah I
can't do that I would that what's you
know why they
changed in our just to defy the you know
I'm saying the the rules when they get
in America oh really yeah just to go
against them that's what I heard
do you know I don't know Google that why
do white Americans drive on the up side
of the road I'm pretty sure they're like
oh you do it here like this in London
yeah and then went against everything
and it's also like the metric system in
the US the US and I think that London to
an extent we they deal with Stalin and
stuff but yeah the most part of the
Grimm's
yeah but they but mostly yours is on
kilograms on the metric system but then
what's interesting is enough suits the
you guys can yeah look this or then i'll
look at the sun um always going to say
the just double still use the euros they
do yeah yeah w years and then love you
pal hound yeah yeah and i think we
before the overall the yeah the runnin
always use the pound sterling and but
this whole great fishing is that this
whole brexit thing is still they still
don't really know what's going on
because a lot of companies are moving to
Ireland and places like that so I get it
yeah a lot of banks and stuff are you
know because they don't really know
what's going on so breaks it could turn
out to be a complete disaster or London
will be a tax haven depending I don't
know will say or the taxes in lemon I
assume or bad how is it when the most
expensive city in the world oh well
London is the center of banking you know
along with New York right so so but
their square foot like to buy a house
imp oh my god oh my god I think learning
is number one yeah yeah because again so
many of these countries that don't have
stable economies who don't trust their
own economies don't trust their own you
know whether it's Russia whether it's
China whether it's even the Middle East
they're buying up they bought up all the
property so crazy crazy to the city of
Incheon yeah it's just that places in
Europe were designed more for
left-hand-drive driving like when you're
sitting in your no we get while Europe
does we're saying what's America yeah
they said well America is because Henry
Ford built the Model T to where he was
on the left-hand side of the car so it's
better for him the job on the right-hand
side I'm sorry
yeah that's it take your car downstairs
and lipstick honor there's a little it's
a conch I saw a lava orange I call good
steak Lawrence make me a little horny
I'm not gonna lie I never saw crap maybe
horn hot so I saw ass in the back yeah
Oh leaders are here one of the biggest
influences of driving direction was
Henry Ford who designed his Model T with
the driver on the left that meant the
cars would have to drive on the would do
she might do that to go against it and
say it so far but it said any other
countries didn't follow out of
stubbornness so like places in Europe
their roads are more designed for the
left-hand side you know the cars were so
they just out of stubbornness they
didn't want to do interesting also good
like out their chin almost died several
times because of all time you know how
here when you're going down the road we
cross the street yes you look left to
right yeah it's right to left
yep Jim would look left and walked out
will the car be coming in hi handsome
dammit ah that happens all the time
they've just life several times he did
good that happens all the [ __ ] time
in London it's how the temple mile the
time they do they do and I just got
nervous thinking about it because that's
what I told you guys clops already get
hit by a bus and it's a testify before
it the court oh really you guys like an
oh yeah a bus bus you know really bus
it's not good at like she said she was
like oh that's awful and then you know
how it was joke around filming yeah yeah
she was like well hell yeah oh yeah I've
been just game oh yes here later cheese
wig choose teeth legging [ __ ] okay
that's what happens it's not horrible
time this I I had a friend warble ago
like that is it I guess not I had a
friend it was a cop who would send me
crazy [ __ ] like he'd send me like stuff
from sort of their archives like where
one day they were chasing and he jumped
at his drug guy or whatever and he
jumped off a building like he jumped off
this yeah give you my head in blood and
he would have been fine if I would have
like landed you know he but it was like
a I don't know like two story and he
sent me a picture and I just see a body
and I see a head on offense and what
happened is he had John
and he caught his head his chin on the
spike of the of the yeah so his body
detachment had in his head was perfectly
mounted on the spike of the you know to
get the defense that one would hurt yeah
it was a wrought iron you know wrought
iron yep head came right off then he
showed me a thing I just got a thing and
said you still think motorcycles are
safe and [ __ ] this guy's on a moped in
China into the intersection and a semi
just goes and doesn't see him and he
goes that and gets up then I'm telling
you man you ever take a fly-in and kill
it and smash it like that exactly the
same thing this what really do it I mean
but it it mashed him like it you got to
get out your spatula rock pit oh my god
yeah
not a good all right step dark yeah hey
you get those friends who send you stuff
like hey I don't like that I don't want
some elements of mom my counselor would
send me that nasty honest he's a poo
monster yeah I call my my capitalism
with that who send me just nasty shots
with girls and just yeah like god damn
it man yeah thank hey Mike hey Don I got
responding you see Stella tone down he's
gonna hit this one true we get him back
on man I love that guys like I go back
to him great guy really do Mike
Catherwood
have you met him - no I don't think so
he's got a show right now he's doing a
bunch of stuff yeah feeling dr. Jewish
still doing her thing but not Loveline
anymore they've lived that billboard off
the 405 I see it man um he's gone but he
stood beyond Jason else's show every
Friday case let me talk to him uh he
texted me but I was in England I'm sure
he's doing well it shows those people
they moved to a new time tattoo on his
head aggressive yeah it is indeed chin
almost got back to on his neck you can
double it yeah come on in Jerry I swear
to God I can't talk about it you just
wobbling you're like something about
Dublin
what was the tattoo gonna be a horseshoe
you know I can't listen
and you're a grown man and there are
definite postures hey action how about
because we were all wrong we all know
where I'll go all it with I'll get
tattoos and then I was drugged right or
[ __ ] onion that you don't have any
that means you have a shitload tattoos
but it's really good you have any
tattoos you get on your neck and chin
just Lucas goes on that I'm down I want
you're not getting your neck heals yeah
well yeah my neck so we go the tattoo I
don't scare me we go to tattoo artists
in Dublin and he drops it up and then
he's like were you on it and she was
like a my neck and he's like no not do
you have any tattoos I guess I'm up on
your neck it's a Jetta
he's a Kip yeah multiple times you just
made reasons why my good man shouldn't
do it so later on we met him again at
the pub yeah like I mean I couldn't let
you do it yeah yeah he did it dude
I like that guy Fatiha that's so funny
again on my neck you have any other
tattoos nope want to start on the neck
hey then how about I tell Jenny oh dude
if he on your neck you print see me piss
soon we shouldn't goes bro up 40 times
40 I always forget olds in it yeah but
also 40 we can't get it you can't get
your first tattoo on your neck well you
can Jan 40 I think a lot of first that
40 sounds fun I guess warmish urged up
forwarding songs well I guess war
machine has had gotten Mac on his neck
right oh you know that like wow we're
just here doing them so yeah I mean
let's tattoo the regressive man neck
tattoo is that one what scares me is I
saw a guy yesterday who was in a truck
and he had tattoos and then he had a big
teardrop on his face
yeah and he looked rough you know I'm
always like you know if it's if you big
don't sort of see one that I don't know
but if you get a tattoo on your face if
that's where you're gonna go
there's no how about where in Chicago
are you done with the show this guy goes
hey come to the 40/40 club with set job
watch the fights we're walking down the
street that it's a it's a nice
restaurant of this Ching so Chin's I
came out with a blonde girl he's just
his street smarts isn't the best let's
be real Tim it's bad it's really really
bad
Tim aside several times if you probably
feel safe with the big man uh I always
feel safe with with
oh and J but so we're trying to get to
this 40/40 club I pity these Hells
Angels outside this place it's a private
party this is not where I'm doing a UFC
viewing party now Ching goes here it is
he's a head of skills what's up man
that's guiding the guy he goes he
doesn't mean J ketchup no no no the
Hells Angel he did two of them full they
had the full thing on throwing a party
there's no signage it's just a glass
it's a [ __ ] steel cage you get in oh
boy and I go chin this isn't it are you
shittin this is not it genius no there's
a party in here I'm like Nick and the
gallows just we just goes you guys at
the wrong party brother I went yeah we
sure are have a good night
I like that gentleman you [ __ ] me
are you [ __ ] me
Don't Tell things does you think our
[ __ ] guarding the place we're looking
at chicken wings watch but this was in
Chicago yeah you looked atomized cuz
you're the wrong place man or something
like that so I remember just serious
yeah one place yeah yeah definitely know
what you're correct
you're correct sir that's like the
ravenite Club John Gotti's ravenite club
so we seeded Cafe Sorrento down in
Little Italy the ravenite Club was
literally three doors down now
the limousine would pick up plug and you
have a [ __ ] giant gorilla with a
earpiece in his ear and then I never saw
John Gotti get off where you see serious
dudes get out and they go to John
Gotti's a rave a nightclub it was a
black mirrored window and a door of
course now you probably not allowed it
was so great to watch like tourists and
people that go by and they go what's in
here well it's just a club or something
or a bar get the [ __ ] yeah they'd
always be like not a private club those
chin
those Hells Angel party yeah not like
we're gonna know my part of a Hells
Angel if I see biker gang killing
everything I do out of me I Drive away I
stole your obably nice it probably
caught up in that world win you know
what it's not Satan we're just that it
was like that art friend who did bit
does business with with a biker gang and
he said you know and he said look I'm
friends with some of these guys they're
all good guys but they're grizzly bears
you got to remember you're not a grizzly
bear you you want to hang out with
grizzly bears it's fine always remember
you
not a grizzly bear so don't get too
chummy so y'all be like each other hey
and then another guy comes from another
chapter he might be cool this chapter he
doesn't know the [ __ ] you are you know
so you're not you're not a grizzly bear
I mean I like to respect to us a little
trouble I'm trying to relax well the
thing about you is that you are a
fighter and a giant man and I would
imagine very tough dudes like Hells
Angels guys there might be a couple guys
in there who say hey you [ __ ] you want
your patch go fight that guy for sure
you know I don't know how they do that
but I can see young man Talon I'm sorry
Karl and I had a bounty on her head when
we were supposed to do a show in Grand
Junction and yeah the sheriff was like
no I can't go down there because there's
a biker rally here in the Hells Angels
and someone else there's a bound if they
can beat when you guys up yeah that's
what you just don't need that I'm out
you don't need it there's no appearance
that I want to do for that yeah why
can't we just be friends I like to try
some cool grappling techniques to help
them with their enforcement and give
their money how about that how about put
a seminar on there you go now I won't
fight you guys but I will show you [ __ ]
a few things you can do to get your
money little couple things you things to
crank your neck down
super easy techniques for you guys yeah
and that's my time I've had you I've had
I've had I've been in I've been in the
clutches couple times yeah [ __ ] chin
man almost ghost killed in Chicago I
thought it was dangerous place
it is a South Side still pretty pretty
rough yeah I was handling death well it
was a year what city were we yet and it
felt blast once last month was their
all-time worst what city was is Len Ono
wondered um live for you which one we're
going to pub and they were the cab
drivers like yeah make sure you're not
there past midnight did a little
stabbing you know what he's having my
dublin said that i were two places I was
in Limerick and I was in a place called
Bognor Regis in England which is kinda
likely the British Riviera but not known
for the post people don't like this you
know it's like this really kind of rough
I'm telling you dude for the livering
they said you don't go out don't go out
gets a little stabby
same thing you get bad I've heard that
from more than three people stabbed is a
word I was in Bognor Regis and I went to
a bar we were all shooting thing for
discovery I'm telling you man I saw I am
Telling You I think I saw 15 fights just
knows I'm not kidding
I saw 15 [ __ ] fight including girls
fighting I could really do non kidding
man
I did like liquidus and then a guy came
out and he was wearing certain pants and
these these two skinny dudes but they
were a rough-looking they were like you
can't you [ __ ] cover that stupid yo
Superman filing and just looking a fight
I was like what's going on here man I'm
like a low-powered I'm still using that
stabby stir everything you got a stat
head we better get out of skinny a
little stab you up in here yeah cuz no
guns right I got strong gun control
doesn't mean I can't bring my pointer
Rather's you have a point of the goddamn
gun oh yeah but it begins that America
we better get out a little gummy up in
here guess little gun we done done oh if
you think you're loving jacked or
anything else is gonna stop a gun gun no
blade all blade I had to cut you up well
I just take my chances
homeboy with a blade that I gun there's
no but I heard there's a guy who teaches
knife fighting yes I took a knife
fighting class why I was with Doug David
off of the Sam Sheridan Sam is writing a
book so this guy was teaching knife
fighting and I never forgot the guy goes
mmm said well for me you know I have my
knife is no longer than my finger I can
scribe your spine from the front
I went excuse me sir you said scribe
because I'll scribe your spine and he
goes now you look like you're in shape
and he's like yeah yeah well no scary
guy and he goes he goes you're in shape
and he had me stand sideways and he took
his thumb and his index finger and he
put it like he kind of like oh now
you're about eight inches wide at the
waist because congratulations you're in
shape and he does not take a six inch
blade and I would I'd open you up and I
in other words I get so deep I'd hit
your spine i just opened you up cutting
that I was like well I got a stomachache
listeners and then he goes like this any
goes
cuz I mean people don't realize about
knife fighting he goes I mean you train
and everything but if I open you up on
your arm if I just open your up right
here and he just went he just dragged
his finger down bucking he goes he goes
he losing hydraulics in about eight
seconds I drop hydraulics I hope but
what do what's wrong back gonna be a
knife expert I guess he was certified in
not eating
he studied Escrima which is Filipino
knife fighting that [ __ ] is nasty and he
see you know how they trained you know
how they trained knife fighting when the
Philippines are here well they trained
at his dojo which is by the way in
Culver City I think his name is mark
over city and I fighting yes sir who you
my super skeptical hit blood yeah he's
white ah he's an athletic tall handsome
man and what's that and he and he he
walks in the yeah well yeah
and he basically overseeing that so he
teaches knife fighting and he's got
students got some students seven got
about seven to seventh loyal students
you've never been in a knife you are
correct by the way that's exactly right
but they trained general act is nice
ladies well guess how they practice with
rubber knives no would Bank modernize
not with butter knives with date look
out Lee here's a hint
you get touch with them they hurt like a
[ __ ] what is it electric knives
no electric knife you hit with them you
get into it I got like that T to like
light sabers basically light sabers they
got to [ __ ] light sabers yeah so now
you're fighting with a knife you're
sparring and you know it really hurts so
you have to learn how to you know keep
the guy at bay yeah every time something
oh yeah okay there's another book a
great book called if I was a little sign
up for martial arts and knife fighting
Culver City would literally be dead
laughs Wow yeah like yeah I skip that
yeah I mean if you're gonna use a knife
or just carry a gun and
I mean in other words what's the name of
your dojo we play for keeps I'm just
going to teach it to do life fighting
yeah um the Peter Pan yeah no no it's
it's that kind of stuff is evil is the
knife fighting I have a black belt in
knife i I don't know - yeah have you
guys ever almost been stabbed sure
haven't
No thank God because you don't almost
get stabbed a lot of times like in book
of five rings Miyamoto Musashi's book
you ever heard of that book it's a great
book and it's I like the book is about
practice when you do something over and
over again yeah you know it's like
you've mastered something yeah and he
was the first apparently samurai to use
two swords and battle he had signal
battles and stuff like that but he said
in real life and real sword fighting you
almost never parry like this almost
never a king team-teaching like myself
it's it's the first dude to the sky oh
yeah right I mean you would know as a
fighter first yeah yeah I would have
been like like the first two to say like
that like like you know and tell your
Polaski you're not blocking it yet not
enough with a samurai sword ever
anything it touches is coming off so
those guys would practice pulling and
striking pulling and striking and he
said very rarely sometimes somebody
misses and then you but it's it's the
universal yeah yeah first afire it's
like this it's like so so when I spar
boxing you have your practice you have
maybe some patterns that you practice
from the names yeah and yeah and you
then you go oh okay I have this I'll do
this and then use for the other day I
was sparring God has got seven amateur
fights not a lot smaller guy than maybe
is better and the difference when things
are moving and when you're when you're
nervous about getting hit and you're
jumping around it all [ __ ] lose
Boston's in this training and there's
fans to this so they're two different
different sports what I always say about
tennis where I play in tennis we've got
higher guys a pro I'm hitting the ball
[ __ ] well see but you're not and
you're not doing Ted I'm not doing
tennis he's not playing to people to
look out for now I tried
it's not try getting a game off him well
yeah but if you actually played tennis
that you would learn exactly Lipton
until the guy who teaches me I started
playing testicles hey he's great he goes
uh I don't want you playing yet I was
like why cause if you want to play then
you can start playing and going
tournaments but right now I just need
you to yeah absolutely
I'm fifty I got a lot of time to really
work on you guys just groove your stroke
right now dude I love about these guys
you pay like Wayne wants you to fight
you pay them the tennis guy wants to
join the tour not a shot yeah Wayne's
always try get me to file of David Lee
again people's get it confused you're
not boxing all the best to the paving
guy to hold the mids yeah that he did
this is an athlete there's different in
him and me is like it was his 25th
anniversary his wife said wakes mom goes
25th anniversary he goes for what
because when you won your silver medal
for Ireland well that's cool yeah and he
goes and he goes yeah and somebody said
congrats you know he saw his wife was
talking about it I go what he goes I had
won my I got my silver medal
I said that's amazing man he goes well
yeah to me I lost the gold to you I want
to show it [ __ ] and that's it that's a
world that's a champion that's not oh my
god I never thought of that salad hey
congrats with 25 years you'll get second
place here yeah I would never think that
way because I'm not an athlete on that
level notice how I said on that level on
that low yeah it is it's really
interesting to hear the difference
between like what you're willing to do
with it yeah I mean wins it was a
monster then yeah well that's the other
hilarious thing for me is sometimes I'll
move around with him put on my headgear
and you'll just show me some stuff and
you know I've been doing it for 3 years
dude so sometimes in my mind what why
does Wayne let you do like the Floyd
Mayweather thing with your handbill
oh I'm just I'm just [ __ ] around we
get a fair video oh I was just going for
the video but sometimes because I've
mastered the cross guard that I've I've
seen you do that before yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't work so well you know weird
leave some time it's a nice overall
right but i I've been doing it three
years and when smaller than me lots
so you know maybe we start I started
throwing punches at him and stuff like
that it's very interesting how he comes
in he gets close to me gets super close
to me real quick it's what he does yeah
blinds me and it gets in close and he
said the same gym yeah glove works still
good I love him I love that man
oh [ __ ] his own gym yeah that's yeah
it's a bummer
yeah it's a bummer man I wish he did too
um just a truly humble good prize he
always been a great guy did you wonder
if he could go back to Ireland open it
he's a big name there yeah it's not yeah
well like you did what you have to
that's what that's what amazing to where
America where should let him give a [ __ ]
it's incredible like I like I feel so
much competition out there there's so
much competition it's so much
competition and I know several fighters
and Wayne's not one of them but I know
several fighters and I am you know them
too um who now that they've retired from
fighting or having a [ __ ] really hard
time and because so much of your life
was dedicated to one specific skills I
don't know too many to the halogen I'm
thinking of a couple in particular but
that you and I know together yeah I mean
I'll see [ __ ] Uncle Creepy oh no I
got I've retired he's such a smart guy
though I'm a and I feel like he's such a
smart dude very smart he has his hands
in a lot of business I think he'll be
funny time to get out of this rut I
really need to reach out to UM first
thing you guys know who retired the one
guy the one guy who I got to know a
little bit and was really amazed and
surprised at how smart he was as in like
well-read yeah was Jake Shields it's
just more contagious what yeah he's
possible judicial smart [ __ ]
he was smart with his money that's oh
I'm sure I think that guys we know that
I retired Jake's killing it yeah I'll
tell you later could I've been thinking
about it and I kind of a little bit
trying to try to help our lobsters you
know you have to get another one you
know holidays over no he just got a gig
that's the way that movie ends man yeah
he just got a gig that's good yeah yeah
anyway
I can we make you Millions you know so
much of everything is just trying to
reinvent yourself sometimes what what do
you what do you get at what do you
everything takes maintenance
everything's worth you good at that's
tough to say to a fighter you know if
they I didn't good at reading but I
don't think it's reinventing yourself I
think kids I just think that sometimes
like but a lot but a lot of times like
like when you say they're not doing well
compared to who I do you compute this
sometimes I think they come out and
they're 40 or they're 38 and they
literally don't have because they've
been doing one thing they don't really
have transferable skills into a job
market that's what I meant
depends what a job market well like what
far as holding busy they know martial
arts yes yeah again that's a huge job
well that's also hard to find I've got a
job market that pays well it is it's
hard to find you can get in a gym but
you know again it's very competitive
it's very competitive yeah you got apply
yourself but y'all you guys poor me poor
me what are you doing that's yeah but up
but love that by the way that I feeling
sorry for you know but also they
dedicate all those years to fighting
when you get out how did you think this
movie end well that's what I'm so sorry
I mean they're gonna be doing well if
you seem on TV I don't I never
understood this when people are all
they're not doing well they have a roof
they have money they'd be you know I'm
saying like do not really think a lot of
times what I noticed would not just with
the fighters a lot of people is that
they tend to like I was talking to a
community about this one times like yeah
I'll listen them they tend to not
actually know how to they're not facing
the real problem they're not facing like
they're not taking actual actual action
because they haven't learned to think
things through that way you know like a
lot of times you'd be like well if your
time solve this problem why are you
doing this over here it just depends
awesome the fighters you're talking to
if they're reaching out for you for help
fight in trouble in the first place if
you're calling Bryan Callen you think
it's gonna change your life you know Kay
thank you I probably send my directions
somewhere else you know I'm saying I do
like the ones I know except the guys I
know you're doing very well
yeah how's Shane doing here do you ever
talk to him
always been doing engineer eight six
figures and since I've known him because
he's a beast engineer we had a small
time job like he's always at a whole
time Electrical Engineering yeah uh I
think of heaters right no no you even I
eat a legit engineer I believe uh what's
the water he deals with water for the
city really those Shane's always been
yeah great what he's happening really
yeah so I said I'm at Sloan's a giant
crib out there yeah Shane's ringtone
forever yeah I mean it but it's also
it's like anything like I know I know
he's talked [ __ ] about fighting stuff
like that but name another sport we get
done and we get look at Marines look at
look at actors like that everyone's a
point out fighters all the time name any
job we dedicated your entire life for
and then it's over and they just in the
full-back and interesting because you
you what I knows with actors is that
they have never worked right so you'll
be 40 and you wake up and you're like
damn this I came here when I was 22 I'm
40 it just hasn't worked out but in the
meantime they've had to work another
[ __ ] so they they're yoga instructor
massage therapists they have a business
they have a dog-walking business you
know what I'm saying yeah a lot of times
when you're a fighter because of maybe
the training what it requires and stuff
like that you didn't really or you still
you making some money not a lot of thing
is we always say this about fighters
fighters will look at other sports
I know people dedicate way longer years
of their life to football you know when
you get down with football there's
nothing nothing there's money though
yeah money well not really I was talking
to I was talking to to middle
linebackers who are a tool of works yeah
they were they play pro oh my god are
they giant like I was like they just
come out of the NFL they just retired
they just retired and I was like about
why you know me I walk and I go what's
with the specimens like the
craziest-looking like linebackers legit
linebackers I play for the Queen Ives
and I was talking about I was like I was
saying like what's it like you guys are
young you're in the prime of your life
is alike and yeah and you and you're
just trying to figure out what to do
with your energy you know and they both
were like yeah that's that's the biggest
challenge right now but then I was like
they were so regimented that's anyone
like you get out of college oh yeah and
I'm sick of Fighters a
and athletes oh poor me poor me when you
got a college so how many people are
lost
yeah out there they're saying for me but
I think they're lost I think a lot of
people are lost who's in hot men you
know I'm saying like other people are
yeah kind of people it's about finding
what to do didn't do what you want to do
with your life well also in an Internet
economy that's changing so fast they
were talking about when you're a
computer at a science major now and you
go to school the first two years you
study by the third year at the two years
you'd studied are obsolete that's how
quickly [ __ ] or computer sighs yeah yeah
that's like there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] like that like and then you like
how the world is changing
do you know who I think this is the
right statistic do you know the three
four countries that have the most
English speakers without besides the
United States most English young people
would the largest population of people
who speak English what are they also
include yeah I'll see London okay no
your kids not up there no you can't do
spin or Annette not in the UK not the
United Kingdom and not Australia so I've
heard it's subtle from what I heard it
is China it's soon to be China it's
going to be the number one speaking
country in the world just by the sheer
any number of people because they study
English Nigeria China well how will hock
it is done how well - rocket nozzle is
there fluent
well there there so when you when you
say when you say English you are able to
work in an english-speaking job market
booth flew so when so when CNN had this
argument with Stephen Miller who's
Trump's campaign adviser our policy
advisor about immigration they're like
okay so only English they were trying to
prioritize people who speak English to
get in this country and who are skilled
workers and he's like oh so now he's
just going to let Australians in and
English people in and they have priority
and Stephen Miller should have said you
know according to this journalists who
said he shouldn't have said he should
have said well actually there are more
English speakers in Nigeria Pakistan
China and India than there are in
Australia for example or in London or in
England I was a little really
interesting yeah but the world is
changing that the demographics and the
sheer numbers of the news
Bua yeah I mean it's it's it's not so
new I mean this is something that people
talk about all the time and this is
where the economy starts to start starts
to shift where automation where
english-speakers where everything starts
to change where China is losing like
8,000 jobs at a time because in China
you got a factory so your your Nike
sneaker they got always thought these
are good do you got these yeah really
well but these are always people who are
who inspect a sneaker right so a Nike
City comes out and you got people all
day looking to make sure that the
sneaker has all the specs well sounds
good except for start-up company comes
in and goes hey guys we got a box with
all these cameras in it you just put the
can't you please put the might night you
can put the sneaker right through it
like for a couple seconds to Zoop and
it'll it'll look at all the specs and
when it doesn't it'll shoot it over this
seismology some 8,000 people out of a
job in China
see oh and by the way we don't need to
have a factory there let's just move it
over to Oregon that's what's happening
this whole economy is changing its the
job pocalypse and they say if you want
to compete in the 21st century you got
to learn unlearn relearn that's are
they're saying a lot of like old old
talking heads I have a hard time doing
social media marketing okay me like
everything like they just they don't
advance and then it's just the world
goes boom see ya boom see ya it's yeah
I've had that in me I I don't know
technology it's like a block it's an
emotional mental block which I've had a
confront I mean I you know older people
for sure like learning like anything
yeah so advanced and it's advancing and
changing and knowing that things are
changing all the time except for
podcasting pound up buddy come on let's
do some kernel veinte up is hard why did
you go for it let's go piss let's go
this have a diamond shaped piss holes
what do you got it is again there's one
club you can't lazy bro yeah you get
lazy crap we a long day my man hey
apparently we played the whole song on
that guy we're playing like all headed
fish it was all it doesn't matter which
always would my wife is like hey I
listened to the whole goddamn song
armoires Emma her guy
I just left doing cuz I don't leave the
video and the audio was lower oh I don't
mind that was over okay we're talking no
a lot of my cut I cut to where when you
guys say stuff yeah I'll just put that
in but not even I need is still long for
them matter so alright so the first
convent what we know we talked about
yesterday that speech that Trump made
yeah that little warning yeah apparently
was all improvised and not a rise his
aides had no idea what he was doing here
knew he was going to deliver a message
but you know loose man addressed of
course he's always been a loose cannon
he surprises the [ __ ] out he says hey
what are you doing your man you're
threatening a nuclear annihilation even
so some in problem wall rankly the world
has never known I'll drop a bomb on
those [ __ ] god damn it and he's a
really emphasizes when he's mad he
flashes his teeth hey have you seen that
the guys I forget what he does but
they're usually generally right about a
lot of things for digging politics and
their over-under was 18 months for Trump
every something came out with a new
release you I think he was the same guy
who predicted Trump was going to be in
office Susan oh this guy professor from
American University anything right I
don't know if that's him but he was date
went ruined Trump got elected he said
the over-unders 18 months
everyone's calm crazy and then I think
he came out and said it's less than that
now well as Mueller the the special
counsel who is really very very well
respected and was the head of the FBI if
he subpoenas and if there's if there's
enough sort of evidence that Trump had
secretly delicious
well night into tie-dye like this all
diseases nothing turns out the you know
they could be
very bad the idea that for example Paul
Manafort it was his campaign manager was
a meeting with Russian you know
operatives to essentially disrupt the
Hillary Clinton campaign that would be
campaign meddling that would be election
meddling and the thing Jesus going to
resign huh I don't know man I don't I I
don't know what will happen I think if
you come to like listen man it's all
good
nothing's gonna happen yeah walked away
he'd bail hell yeah I'm out this is
horrible I think as he goes I think
that's like a though that's why I'm
saying the only reason he's I can do
this is ego yeah
but if there was some sort of push
button we could go back in time I baby
you wouldn't do it but I also wonder how
much a president especially Trump is
hearing how much a president is privy to
because a lot of Latino is there's so
much hate that a lot of times he gets
they inflate Trump so apparently they'll
show him things where his name is
mentioned a lot he watches how I really
aware of how it looks like he's hated I
probably super says yeah yeah cuz he
likes he likes to be famous yes oh yeah
he thought it was a popularity like he
listens nobody worried like I do you
don't said yeah like you go from being
this billionaire to [ __ ] this but
apparently they keep that [ __ ] from him
when they they're afraid he'll be in a
bad mood like a friendly as advisors
like don't show off that party of these
on his part yeah because he is he's I
thought the handle yeah he [ __ ] up I had
to people love you yeah a punch you in
the face
chin John Young in Luo Jin Jin Young Jin
jong-un whatever your name is I don't
care all those goods frankly you have a
stupid face frankly you have a stupid
face from Korea from Koreans are
beautiful people but you have a dumb
face and I'm nuclear nuclear missile
your face like they just went improv I
he goes his people are like ass Jared
Rath and fire and frankly power but then
he said it again confessed because he
adds that what was it what was it dude
fire and and never seen there's a fire
and destruction like you know and
frankly power huh
thanks thanks Don
goddamn it's good I tell you I played
golf with a guy who caddies for him
periodically no oh I didn't oh my god so
my buddy Cameron who was on syrup great
guy so he's a guy who was over my
shoulder
teach me on a golf I'm [ __ ] hitting
the ball I'm killing my daddy takes
lessons I'm like you hear about the
Walmart they're building my father goes
what do you hear about the Walmart
they're building he goes where I go
between my ball and your balls yeah yeah
I was [ __ ] to this but this guy he's
over my shoulder basically Talmadge's
I'm [ __ ] my my putting is amazing
this in Utah this new table Trump's up
Trump he's carried four George W Obama
Trump guess who his favorite presidents
by far Obama Trump really he said he's a
[ __ ] blast even like there was how
you think I'm doing because it looks
like you're busy as hell really good for
you got a lot on your plate honey don't
do it but he said he's always asking you
know he said he said he's funny he said
he's a complete guy who died Gaia but
grandma till then he does weird [ __ ]
like he said Trump was never driving by
in a cart and Trump these two these the
couple were at his you know at Key Largo
what's it called Marla Varla Varla
hallelujah and he pointed them as job
line he goes do you guys have any idea
how lucky you are
[Music]
do you have any idea how lucky you are
and apparently is pretty good good
golfer yo you but you have any ideas
horrible presidents yeah that's cool
beautiful day yeah that's me I say they
[ __ ] hilarious
got a great sense of humor do you have
any idea how lucky you guys are and he's
a really good worlders like friends not
as much even [ __ ] legit golfer now
Diana that begin with DM is Michael
Jordan's
caddy like he spent a lot of time with
my dude and Michael Dell bet Michael
short game ah apparently is as good as
many pros yeah for the and he said that
when he bets like he'll spot him like
they'll bet and when when it's all on
the line that motherfucker's and he goes
he goes how do you do it and Jordan goes
I always go back to fundamentals yeah
I'm also want to grade yeah but so
serious golf thing let's relax
you don't play I feel like you would
like it I like golf I just don't have
time
yeah I also don't have John you know
what goes neither Getty Caulfield you
don't do yeah I mean you don't anytime
you're not doing so that's why you play
when you're retired yeah exactly it
takes five hours five hours to 18 holes
yeah four or five hours I just simply
don't care I do like I like golf if I
had more time
yeah who's really good and he tried out
for the straight-up Pro Tour was Tony
Romo Jose Jesus scratch Golf really yeah
he barely missed the cut - Wow
yeah super really really making tutorial
it's weird a lot of quarterbacks are
really good at golf
like Joel Klatte who's the head college
football analyst for Fox Sports you know
he's my quarterback in college he's
always been [ __ ] good at golf I bet
they're so I know yeah we're backs are
really really good at golf man yeah I
wonder why
what is kitchen okay please stop Trump
are you so out of shape right go
II just know that's the other is oh so
I've read out funny I brought up on that
no so Trump has this idea basically that
so he had a guys to work for him who was
a triathlete and you're gonna die early
no I don't I don't you you so many beat
yeah I said you know is a bad way yeah
yeah don't you new battery battery up no
no no so he like some people were like
that they're like I get a workout when I
make speeches and when I walk around you
know they like think I'm fine it's not
real big guy and yeah beat no big noise
he's old piece he said I shake that guy
yeah oh yeah always when we did that
White House story they're saying how he
uh you know he's only president like
once like chili cheese fries and hot
dogs yeah the time oh he's a terrible
he'd have all the food in the world he's
like chili cheese fries hot dogs yeah
pornos Carol made him hilarious to me I
feel like my Grammy in him would be so
fun together
we'd be so out of shape you have you you
in a way do you do you have a an end
mark where you might just go I'm gonna
let it all go
no I can't I don't have the u2 vein
right yeah I wish I did yeah life would
be so much on now because you like
fashion you want to look good in
something you can't be fit not mad that
jacket thanks man
might have to get that jacket you can't
get online absolutely time to go to
London that's why I bought it I can't
get it can't get it here nope
why not uh
no now I want more to do it me too well
now when I had a gear like I know I wish
you had I would show you like blue one -
I could use a nice suede leather jacket
you have one I don't and I could use a
nice I could really use a nice suede
leather jacket I was gonna go with blue
but I thought you know what I have a lot
of blue so will this bank giving that
jacket away right no go do not just to
give this away now
you got to buy the goat there's a lot of
stuff that goes into it just slapped a
stupid porns yeah what else judge said
speaking of London this dude I'll show
you the video here he pushed a girl as
he's jogging down a street in London he
pushed a girl that was walk I was
walking towards him into the with in the
way of a bus I believe two gay guys
dressed in the mobile yeah corner bunny
tail yes here a temporary insanity chick
did he have to step mom to this does she
die no look look how lucky she is though
so he's jogging and he pushes her boom
the bus swerves Dan up bus drives on
some [ __ ] fast and furious
well da worst a jogger right there you
see her the block the block clothes lady
yeah then he pushes her here as the bus
is coming towards him the video sucks
but why does he do that no one knows and
he just continues jogging maybe he
thought he was upset because she
wouldn't move yeah maybe that like maybe
it was just like get away but also I
would never do that
like I would move out of the way she's a
woman she was walking on the street
probably he didn't get a stiff arm with
it but he never pushed her down I didn't
understand stiff arm in the [ __ ] but
understand Jose Simpson with husband
Todd and then Chris Evans let them lie
misguide so he had you know Captain
America nah hey bro now you ain't play
roll hey you play roll I like that let's
find this guy I'm gonna be shooting over
here but I'll being a life fine you guys
know I'll be in the Hills that goes for
you guys with my six million follow you
guys flying a that's fine also that
video give me tough to find yeah without
yet they found them they did I wonder as
evidence at our moment
oh no no no a dead by the way the UK
London has more camera yeah they do
you're not getting away with [ __ ]
anything
you're being recording humming this guy
goes note the woman tried to trip the
jogger first watch it slowly then this
guy says no she wasn't he goes watch it
frame by frame I can't really tell about
the but why the driver in the first guy
while we're in no idea about last you
know I feel with that evidence it's
gonna be really hard to convict him
because with a good lawyer he's gonna be
like look she denied you about err us
yeah but I mean what if you did make
contact with someone you have to kind of
like check back right not if you're in
the zone that's not not really not it's
not if you're in car do you know you
know who everybody playing again and
I'll be able to tell you right now
there's no way we're gonna be us not but
I have a very good eye watch this
writing Oh zoom magnin say say oh shut
up she tried to trip him and she really
yeah she put her foot on she's guilty
honest yeah what's what what what's that
watch her right foot I'm frame my friend
there I kick him in the nuts your air
yeah actually he pushes her no no but
she put her way way I don't know she's
on a trip oh my look at one more time I
will get to the bottom of [ __ ] on the F
and K get to the bottom of this there
she is
you laugh you like to try tripping it's
like they both they're the same today I
push baby push
no he would know he know he definitely
pushed her you know that hey B that's
not the argument when that's not dog
yeah her doesn't let go out right there
oh I wonder yeah it doesn't know what
she deserves to be hit by a bus
oh my god she's lucky is she ever
I wonder if they probably knows her the
bus driver is the real MVP mmm boy
that's a that's a weird shitty Gago
mm-hmm that's a shitty guy well the guy
he's like a 41 year old dude ricotta on
and what he said I think they just took
him in he sauce trying to burn calories
that [ __ ] tried
trip to me I've pushed her it had no
idea double-decker bus and run over
skull yeah who could have gone bad let's
see arrested after and did he live and
give any comment oh our boy Joel from
Toronto
yes that much time yeah Joe Garcia our
boy he used listen to find the kid
yesterday
this chin that girl who got kidnapped
yeah he knew all the info on it it shows
the Russian mafia they found out she was
a mother they don't kill mom so that's
why she got it they like they let her go
it was her she was saying I'm a mother
and they were turning scam this picture
of her head right there Instagram save
your life or his games because they she
was like I'm a mother or mother don't do
this because they're you know they're
gonna do some [ __ ] to it and that you
know in their damn ethics you know holy
so they hooked it up with I kill she's a
mom let it go crazy right like Russian
mafia you the real MVP so it was right
now is Romanian mafia Romanian but I
mean that's part of I don't know about
that Romanian mafia Russian mafia it
reminds me that never that scene from
that movie with Denzel Washington and
then on fire no no no and Ethan Hawke
the cop movie training to training days
remember when they were going to kill
Ethan all but he saved yeah he does
measuring gangsters like I saved her
life yeah I saved your daughter's life
they let him go me of that so wait so so
this this Romanian mafia kidnapped her
put her on the dark web for sale
mmm-hmm so somebody could buy her as a
sex slave then they found out she's a
mother jealousy exactly said what the
[ __ ] man another thing I remember
reading is a sheep the captor she said
like if you let me go I'll sleep with
you that was one of the things she said
well you say whatever you have to Boris
so Joel put yo was listening to the new
podcast the model that was kidnapped in
xscape she was released because they
found out she was a mother with a baby
that goes against the principles she was
saved because of her Instagram that's
all the baby I love the idea of
principals is like I okay but I but we
kidnap somebody's daughter you're gonna
run a train on yeah a began we're in a
cellar on the dark web yeah great but
still together you know yeah so the cool
appreciate it yeah right there's some on
our Montilla cool yeah well that's some
people are [ __ ] bad to their core man
just bad to your core you just kidnap a
girl and you're gonna Jesus Christ
little shits in and by the way it's a
group of them to like your your friends
or the guy who does that and and our guy
does that you like the planning but they
grow up like that huh like that's their
custom of that like that's life well I
know for example the Romanian mafia does
and Albania Romania there was these
girls from lot
beautiful girls would sign up to do
domestic tour domestic housework and
stuff they get them there take their
passport and they would just sell them
into slavery well I mean they're not
breaking news don't look for them she
looks just like that movie taken it
reminded me exactly of taking yeah she
was abducted God remember this is funny
guys here's the hard part
they will take you yeah else it is all
good luck good luck what else gets in
all right Paige Vanzant posted this
picture of her foot MRSA no uh no
description but it looks like it's a
huge deep disgusting gash I'd be I don't
think that's Merce another summer sighs
not stat no cuz it don't know yeah skin
folding way we're here so yeah no touch
right through a kick really that cut and
then put tape over it and trained again
that's real sweaty
okay you see things coming off of it
lines almost why you actually notice the
deep mark see faint like mine really oh
yeah Fitz immersive ease and be
discolored damn know what happened is it
possible that she had MRSA and they cut
it out oh no no I bet she she looks like
she didn't praise threw a kick and then
she bandaged his up as a backing he gets
worse and worse
Wow it's pretty nasty though pretty with
well she got chin all right how about
this Boyd Mayweather comment he says
that he's fighting beating Connor is for
all the blacks why did kind of be kind
of what was their thing he said about
monkey nothing at the press convert that
during the president's flu he was
dancing and he was okay yeah dance like
a monkey they go you have to dance like
a monkey but it's it you can tell is the
context is I contact you know they might
okay and they kept calling boy yeah but
that's more that's Irish that's what
cause I was like I'm not racist if we
get yeah yeah look employees you know
he's doing his rounds now trying to sell
the fight yeah he's doing a good job
this one such a stretch you know to get
the black support to finally get the
black support I think
goddamn is out of stretch did he not
have a lot of black support and he does
he doesn't ruin too
you see him lose you know some people
like them but that's a super stretch
alrighty it's not a John John either so
this is MMA that George st. Pierre
finally has signed the bout agreement to
fight Wow I'll quote Bisping wow you
just found about shinobi I am mmm-hmm
I'm screwed garden right yep do you see
- 17 November 4th I think gar Brent and
TJ Dillashaw are all heard that they
wanted a Lyta
I heard cyborg showing John that card
shun fight Holly homes on that a be
great exciting there's nothing that's
just rumors
hmm ah yeah cool good fight
how about this Kylie Jenner she sold her
makeup brand for like four hundred
million dollars and its projected to be
a billion dollar business just like 2022
she's like the leader of all every girl
you've ever met one hundred million
dollars not credible I'll tell you what
I'll try to be a billion dollar by doing
twenty two because that surgery just did
her wonders but an essay she how old is
she incredible twenty
oh not cell so her makeup company is
worth four hundred nine yes but uh yeah
she's like the one they did do an
amazing job with whatever's going on
their science is killed I mean it really
is it I would imagine didn't she have a
booty like that already please tell me
that's a to the drug to her hips are
natural you're smarter than this her
hips are natural though right we saw her
they put it even moved in her ribs and
everything come on Gladys crazy we've
been over this and shut up to her though
what a sketch in how about this good
story a police officer was called to a
guy stealing clothes like a shirt and
tie and all that stuff he needed for a
job interview so instead of arresting
him he just bought the clothes for him
I like that police always are do it man
I like that police officer the guy
bought him the guy stole him in an
impulsive fit of insanity
sure and the cop does he's 18 just
trying to get a job they'd have money so
he was educator for sure
hopefully you got the kid as I say
though you get caught stealing
not the first time you've done it the
first time you got caught true
well this is cross his name is in there
neuron j iran's on what is the jan it
sounds like it's probably indian or
psychology or toronto yeah yeah i'm good
that she indian maybe pakistani near on
Johnson
I like that tub so do i okay this is a
sad one but I know but it's uh it's a
sort of cool so remember that kid that
was killed by an alligator at the Disney
in Harlem nightmare for me and I never
forget repairable nightmare forever
I think you've email after I met I mean
any parent [ __ ] well they made a
foundation form and they had they put
this statue in his honor at the park
it's a lighthouse yeah that's at least
his memory will be there forever and to
his on that the place that's the darkest
place without family sure I'm never
gonna see this trend is no friend to my
in-laws they lost their daughter when
she was twelve I think her nine and the
guy he was a pilot for a very wealthy
man and he built the statue for he made
this basically bronze statue in her
likeness and I just I don't know I don't
know if I want that I don't know if I
would want my god I don't clear either
does that make a difference to me
no it does matter and you still I [ __ ]
locked up all my bathrooms now because I
was well I was when I was by my car the
guys help me buy my car retire my kids
and then he's a little weird about it
and I might tell what's going on and
he's like oh my my three year or two
year old three year old um you know like
we're around the house and we kept our
honor and then she fell into the toilet
and then it's jammed know died yeah like
like we literally let just take your
thighs up for 30 seconds just jim
brewers joke but it's true like you have
kids and I just walk around looking for
death yeah that's what they do that's
like she's constantly trying to make
looking for death death around here oh
there's a Ledge yep
on to this it's called kid mania some
[ __ ] like that
it's a gym and Brentwood for kids and
there's awesome cuz they have this this
big like puffy tire like you can push
tire just like the beastmode the kids
over it you know where all the other
kids kind of cool stand there and the
Tigers kits and just Moe's over these
other kids I should stop it but I watch
it and celebrate inside could you just
come monster it's like no enjoy push
back in just like that does haunt you
just drives got that does legs I go
please stop don't do that please stop
that oh that's hilarious
uh-huh it's a soft ground all right I
got heroin John hurt and we get in the
herb we just this is this bug I got a
full beard [ __ ] tired stealing these
kids no please don't say you're gonna
act like that he's gonna act like that
please this is ridiculous yeah goose he
came out of the window what else get you
check this out these guys used donkeys
to smuggle a car into Zimbabwe from
South Africa and the reason why they do
this you have any idea why they would
use a donkey's to drag this car in the
desert um let me think
mm-hmm why would Marquis know that's how
it was no you [ __ ] terrible detective
well I figure the donkeys would mash up
the tire mine well they don't because
they're pulling it god damn it what do
you think they're doing pushing it like
[ __ ] sled you know what man yes idiot
you know I'm only a detective out
hearable detective where's Turner noon I
don't know about you bro
what would you let me sing : I would
imagine that when the car is on they can
see it with infrared material or it's
just too hot and yeah cuz Zimbabwe has a
bunch of infrared material you're all
[ __ ] know all I happen to know that
they are infrared drones and they're
what is it
balls closer yeah oh yeah yeah why
should the fishing the eye pockit
what risings cuz blah Blee has good lead
in ireland laser because of the infrared
what do you got Jim what is hold on when
it's on when it's on they can detect it
they can detect it because because they
can smell the exhaust what is it Jim
well these are old nicer cars they have
tracking devices they all do computer so
chip it on and running yeah if it's on
again they can track it
okay there's all in car yes stolen I
should have said this why the bull hits
why the smug here's the thing down here
you think lasting more your Ford's not
smuggling cars in axis cell to the
beautiful walking you know you're not
all sir sir it's like building detective
sim right like you stand over there
please lock get behind the tape you got
a to Detective sir oh my gosh you guys
season 1 I'm asking you guys shut up
behind the tape sir no sir and don't pet
the doggies
don't play with their noses and I win
tax I mean there's no feed the doggies
play with their noses while me and chin
talk
now let's GPS screws everything up yeah
but when they turn it on and they're in
Zimbabwe can't they track it been or I
guess they would have to get it before
it leaves look at how but if it's around
other cards is the addict in the matter
makes sense
all of youse odds on the donkey's pull
the fattier Colin but then they just
gave up after Wallis wife yeah no [ __ ] I
was like [ __ ] this I got a lotta yeah
and if all those sleds under the tires
to help the donkey feel like that's a
lot of work for the done a lot of work
poor donkey strong donkeys does it Jim
that's pretty much everything a happy
donkey in your life not once they're
always true P they're cuter than I
thought though an ally should happen I
mean give our donkey yeah he put the
kids ride donkeys right yeah
did you guys play grab they all my kids
don't play dumb you don't right doc that
you ride ponies
there's no donkeys around there okay
now you can ride a mule you can ride a
mule
here's thing about a mule will take you
and they better like you now a mule will
let one person ride them sometimes and
everybody else can go [ __ ] themselves
you'll kick you in the face
it'll also bite you but this strange
yeah a mule is a smart animal compared
to a horse a parent
yeah you can ride dog my kids are
doggies I've ridden donkeys we but you
know if you're riding and learning how
to ride you ride a pony the kids are so
happy
Valek a nice dog to myself you dropping
knowledge
I got a drought now about donkeys it's
about burros and I think it's really
great it's about smugglin colors it is
Chinna yeah everyone just uh
Eddy talking yeah Kyle just keep talking
mind it I'm not gonna find I saw let me
look at more donkey pictures here
there's an old lady with probably her
daughter and then their kids and this
looks like a miniature donkey and then
this kid looks like he's not riding the
donkey for fun it's kind of like he just
has to ride it because that's where
that's what they do here and then this
kid looks Asian your stay in Kyrgyzstan
so that those places they have like a
Asian influence right I think they're
like Park Kareem and stuff there too
just like triple G uh-huh
that's fine he'll looking at fighters
yeah sorry
all good Connie hey you rolling man
don't you're dropping all should be well
I shouldn't have [ __ ] up for once
because I'd be myself I think my show
everyone and I'm so rude
oh my god that's so rude it's not drop
it's not you're dropping knowledge for
reading off for article right now so let
me just google some drop a knowledge for
you no I want here's one for su [ __ ]
faster are you gonna play a video and
then I thought yeah name is so sorry I'm
so ready
mmm-hmm so this is something I thought
was really interesting um this this
essentially is something I heard Steven
jobs say and uh Steve Jobs Steve mr.
Stanko was Steven for God's sake and he
said something I thought was interesting
and um you know cuz I and I break this
down more in my other podcast mixed
mental arts
and I think that I'm getting close with
the help of hunter to in breaking down
how to think about things but this is
something we talked about listen
business Steve Jobs say something
interesting
is he coming up yeah the thing I would
say is when you grow up you tend to get
told that the world is the way it is and
your your life is just to live your life
inside the world try not to bash into
the walls too much try to have a nice
family life have fun save a little money
but life then that's a very limited life
life can be much broader once you
discover one simple fact and that is
everything around you that you call life
was made up by people that were no
smarter than you and you can change it
you can influence it you can you can
build your own things that other people
can use and the minute that you
understand that you can poke life and
actually something will you know if you
push in something will pop out the other
side you can you can change you can mold
it um that's maybe the most important
thing pretty cool new jobs yeah so you
know is what happens we don't limit
yourself don't let me yourself I guess
is what I'm saying I don't I had to
think about that pretty cool a lot you
had yeah and he said that when he's a
young man he said that way before
anything else you know so you can learn
from people who have done big things and
some of it's just a mindset some of it's
not limiting yourself some of its
thinking that I have if I you know if I
have the right tool it maybe I can
surprise myself so go out there and
surprise yourself kids Brennan go out
there and surprise yourself by the way
kids you want to really surprise
yourself and laughs come to Seattle come
to Bellevue parlor life hopefully you're
funnier than Steve Jobs uh yeah
hopefully I was I heard yous a riot
really no the [ __ ] ass really knows
she's an [ __ ] brilliant man yeah hey
that's Daryl just gonna dick no not a
father you kind of seen a bad person
that show um I mean in that movie yeah I
mean brilliant man but you
completely dick yeah yeah but sometimes
you have to be to get where you're going
I guess so I guess so personality traits
you see Seattle Bill Gates is up there
yeah he'll be he'll be at my front row I
do have a lot of I do have a lot of
Microsoft people to come to shows all
the time yeah it's audience yeah and
it's so funny because you can feel it in
the room you know you can feel the
difference between like the Bible
shooter yeah Dubrow so much it's very
interesting go see Brian Seattle humming
long beach end of september t5k dot-com
calm this is the pumpkin we're out